to be easy for any of the eight teams
left in the nfl playoff field including
the green bay packers who are the one
seed in the nfc
we are going to do a draft of the teams
we believe in as the super bowl winner
potentially and we may get to all eight
of them depending on time chris you've
got a trivia question
for me fire away i don't know the answer
to this so i mean i'm gonna i'm gonna
help you out here at least talk it
through with you i'll let you guess i
get it wrong
aaron rodgers tom brady russell wilson
all had 40 plus touchdown passes this
season
who is the only quarterback in nfl
history to throw
40 plus tds in the regular season and
win the super bowl
warner man okay good job
way to go i wouldn't have come up with
that he was certainly on the list of
names i was thinking of but i wasn't
sure he definitely got to 40 that year
so wow way to go you the man well
last guy to be the regular season mvp
and super bowl mvp in 1999
so i figured he had to be north of 40 to
win the regular season mvp and i
remember the greatest show-offs in turf
that year
how how unstoppable they were and uh
that was just amazing how that just
kind of it just happened i mean i
remember at the time thinking
how significant this is and how historic
it is
that this team after trent green tears
his acl
in the preseason and they go to this guy
who bagged groceries and played for the
iowa barnstormers of the arena league
that
that they took the league by storm that
year it's incredible what they did and
yeah it's the last time that the super
bowl
mvp and the regular season mvp were the
same person all right
uh number one for me you got to go with
the chiefs gotta go with the team that
has shown that it can overcome any and
all adversity that it faces it did it in
every playoff game last year
they are arrested they are ready they
are sitting back they are waiting for
the browns it's not going to be easy it
may not be a blowout
but i see the chiefs migrating their way
to tampa and
of all the teams available the team most
likely to win it all chris
yeah i i can't disagree with that that
would have been my number one pick too
and you know i'm really last week threw
a little bit of wrenching
into what i i thought you know i think
we kind of i went into the playoffs
thinking i think the
the bills are one of the two or three
best teams for sure and i'm just not
sure about that i guess last week is
still in my mind and how they got
controlled up front and all of that
so i am gonna change my thought there
and i'm gonna pick the packers i am uh
that's so i'm gonna go with number two
the packers showed me a lot the last few
weeks of the year they really did i
can't lie
you know they just showed toughness on
both sides of the ball
their defense is a little grittier and
tougher than i gave it credit for in the
midway point of the year and everything
like that
you know i think mike penton's done a
really good job they figured out how to
use their personnel the right way
all of that but you know we've talked a
few times about their offense
where yeah last year they were 13-3 and
things were good
but this year it kind of seems like an
unstoppable force and to me where it's
gone
above and beyond is their run game has
gone to a point where it's like
oh you know we're running we don't care
we're still going to run it and we can
do it successfully
and rogers and the offense just the pass
offense seems
more you know vast and more ideas and
things like that this year so i'm going
to go with the packers
before the packers can get to the super
bowl they may have to get past the tampa
bay buccaneers although they may not
have to face them if the saints win on
sunday night the buccaneers beat the
packers 38-10 the buccaneers are my next
choice
i think they are the team from the nfc
field most suited
to winning the super bowl because of the
presence of tom brady and all the times
that tom brady has
played in a super bowl he's got nine
super bowl more than half of his season
he has played of super bowls in his
career
uh so i if they can get there now look
it's not like
it's an easy win over the chiefs but i
just you take the chiefs and the packers
off the board the team that i next feel
best about is the buccaneers in fact i
may have made the buccaneers number two
over the packers
yeah i i don't yeah i mean listen
they're dangerous i get you their
defense scares me though
the way that looked last week uh i'm a
little
a little concerned about that and you
know of course we're gonna see a team
that that dominated that defense here
play them this week i'm gonna go with
the saints off of that
you know i feel a little bit better
about the saints in the bucks not on the
offensive side of the ball
you know the bucks are certainly more
explosive and everything like that but
the saints offense is still damn good
and with that defense you know the way
they've beaten the bucks this year
the way they you know pressured
patrick mahomes patrick mahomes got hit
in that game like i've never seen him
get hit before
you know so i think they are you give
them another crack of the chiefs
and that was drew brees first game back
after a long time off and everything
like that
i think they're one of those teams that
could beat the saints in the super bowl
too so i'll go with the saints as
my second pick my knee-jerk reaction in
this spot is to take the bills
and to say i'm surprised they've lasted
so long and then i stopped and thought
wait a minute they play the ravens this
week yeah and
and i don't want to tip my i don't want
to tip my pick
well you are tipping it you're going
with the ravens it sounds like
i'm going with the ravens i hate to say
this the bills were the number one team
in my
most recent power rankings but hey you
you can't have
a close call like they had against the
colts
and we've forgotten about that game
because it was the first of six
for the weekend that was a close call
close
that was that was a grazing they were
grazed by the colts
and uh that that has to affect how we
perceive them going forward i yeah i
i i'll take the ravens over the bills
yeah i i hear you
yeah i mean i'm with you that was
concerning with what we saw there last
week and you know the ravens have been
one of the hottest teams in football and
you know lamar jackson
uh is is amazing he really is i think i
got a song for lamar jackson too i'm
gonna break out here soon for you
oh yeah yeah uh but yeah i think
my next pick is of course i'm you know
gonna go with the buffalo bills yeah
giddy up giddy up giddy up josh allen
giddy up kitty up it's my boy blue
i i got to but the reason he's at
they're not the number six team here
is because of that right there you know
that that's where i came up with the
song as i was going oh here go
josh allen take over giddy up here we go
jump on
that's how i started messing around with
in my head because that's what we saw
i mean you just said about it like
flirted with danger what they were
outplayed
period they are if they don't have a
josh
allen or a mahomes or a rogers as their
quarterback they're going to lose there
there's no way they're going to win that
game
so that's how special he was and yeah
the bills have fallen in my power
rankings as well
so we're down to the rams and the browns
so who do you want
well i'll i want the rams over the brown
well i'll take the browns
i'll take the browns fine i i
i look and peter king and i were talking
about this some yesterday and we're
going to really delve into it on friday
peter's done some research about the
the chiefs most recent games and and
also
not just that the experiences of teams
that have shut it down in week 17 and
then had the bye week and
how they struggle in the divisional
round and you look at how the browns are
rolling into this game
if they get past the chiefs yeah if
and we do this next week well they can't
be lower than four because there's only
going to be four teams left but we're
going to feel
very very differently about the brown's
chances of getting to the super bowl and
winning it if they somehow go into
kansas city and beat the chief
no doubt you know it's i don't think
it's crazy
you know i don't expect it but would
that run game and chew up the clock
keep my homes by the gatorade bottles
listen i i mean i'm taking the rams as
my last pick
this is what's awesome about this
weekend i wouldn't be shocked if the
rams beat the packers
i don't know what the packers are
favored by but in chris sims's line it
wouldn't be by much
i don't think it would be not with that
defense they're scary
i think they match up very well with
green bay in a lot of ways so
yeah i mean it's no disrespect to the
rams or the browns but there's just it's
it's eight really good teams left
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports